les accidents spectaculaires en plein
centre du vélodrome de montigny le
bretonneux des pompiers de toute la
france se sont donné rendez vous pour
montrer leurs meilleures techniques de
désincarcération et de prise en charge
des accidentés de la route ce matin
l'équipe des alpes-maritimes tenter de
relever le challenge
il avait un cas très difficile avec deux
personnes qui étaient incarcérés dans la
voiture retournée sur le toit
ils se sont bien débrouillés dix neuf
équipes françaises et trois équipes
internationales sont venus participer à
cette troisième édition la compétition
tourne autour de deux épreuves 10
minutes pour extraire une victime
trente minutes quand il y en a deux un
véritable travail d'équipé
orchestré par le capitaine sam vesty de
partage de la connaissance autour du
monde
sapeurs-pompiers de la désincarcération
c'est un objectif qui portait depuis
des dizaines une dizaine d'années au
travers le monde la france est inscrit
dans cette technique depuis trois ans
pour la première fois cette année le
département des yvelines a sa propre
équipe
les huit pompiers se sont entraînés
depuis le mois de janvier pour ces
épreuves prévues vendredi et samedi
c'est une envie ça fait partie de nos
missions aussi de tous les jours en cas
de sapeurs pompiers ça demande un petit
peu de technique l'utilisation de
matériel et puis aussi un petit peu de
réflexion au niveau des accidents de la
route l'événement est ouvert au public
et pour l'occasion un espace prévention
est mis en place à l'extérieur des mille
cinq cents collégiens et lycéens
yvelinois sont sensibilisés aux risques
de la route à travers différents
simulateurs
histoire de rappeler qu'avant de
désincarcérer mieux vaut éviter
l'accident
[Musique]
on leur fait prendre conscience de leur
fragilité
un âge où ils se sentent vraiment très
très fort et ils deviennent de plus en
plus c'est pourquoi ils prennent
davantage de risques et c'est pourquoi
malheureusement les jeunes de 15-24 ans
sont deux fois plus sinistrées sur la
route que les autres tranches d'âge
le challenge extraction les sapeurs
pompiers se poursuit jusqu'à samedi le
vainqueur se qualifiera pour le
championnat mondial cette année en
afrique du sud